Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. I'm joined by Dr. Beth Darnel, a clinical professor at Stanford University, whose research focuses on how to best treat and prevent chronic pain, as well as strategies for opioid use reduction. Welcome Dr. Darnel. Hi, Caitlin. Thanks so much for having me. Of course. We're happy to have you here.
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。今天做客节目的嘉宾是斯坦福大学临床教授贝丝·达内尔博士，她的研究重点是如何最好地治疗和预防慢性疼痛，以及减少阿片类药物使用的策略。欢迎您，达内尔博士。你好，凯特琳。非常感谢邀请我来。不客气，很高兴你能来。
So first, the national discourse right now often focuses on the negative aspects of opioid use. Can you talk about whether it's a positive thing for people to use? Absolutely. So I think when most people think about opioids, they think about painkillers. And opioids can be very beneficial for pain in the short run. So we call that acute pain after surgery or an injury, very brief time-limited use. In fact, a lot of different types of pain, including a lot of pain. acute pain can be well managed with more conservative pharmaceuticals and even without pharmaceuticals
首先，目前全国的讨论往往集中在阿片类药物使用的负面影响上。您能谈谈人们使用它是否也有积极的一面吗？当然可以。我认为大多数人想到阿片类药物时，首先想到的是止痛药。在短期内，阿片类药物对缓解疼痛确实非常有益。我们称之为手术或受伤后的急性疼痛，这属于非常短暂、有时限的使用。事实上，许多不同类型的疼痛，包括很多急性疼痛，都可以通过更保守的药物治疗，甚至无需药物治疗来妥善管理。
at all. But opioids can be beneficial for acute pain. It's when the prescriptions start persisting, when pain becomes chronic. And then the evidence is really limited in supporting their benefit for chronic pain. And as a pain psychologist, what is your perspective of what's currently going on in this country with the opioid epidemic? What's happening right now with, you know, the national discourse on opioids and the opioid epidemic is many different pieces. Number one, a lot of the focus on opioid overdose deaths is really being driven by some illicit use or what we would think of as being addiction. This is really important for us to pay attention to that and to have better strategies to treat substance use disorder and addiction in the country. Now, I'm not in the field of addiction.
但阿片类药物对急性疼痛确实有益。问题在于当处方开始持续，疼痛转为慢性时。目前支持其用于慢性疼痛的证据非常有限。作为一名疼痛心理学家，您如何看待目前美国国内的阿片类药物流行危机？目前关于阿片类药物和阿片类药物流行的全国性讨论涉及许多不同方面。首先，对阿片类药物过量死亡的关注，很大程度上是由非法使用或我们所认为的成瘾问题驱动的。我们必须关注这一点，并制定更好的策略来治疗国内的物质使用障碍和成瘾问题。不过，我并不从事成瘾领域的研究。
I work with individuals who have chronic pain, and most of whom, when prescribed opioids are taking them exactly as prescribed. But what we now know is that opioids aren't the best frontline treatment for chronic pain, certainly, and they come with a whole host of negative side effects. And so we're coming into much greater awareness that we should be treating pain more conservatively, giving individuals with chronic pain a lot of different treatment options, and in particular psychological strategies, so that patients can become equipped to best control their pain,
我主要与慢性疼痛患者合作，他们中的大多数人在被开具阿片类药物时，都是严格按照处方服用的。但我们现在知道，阿片类药物绝非慢性疼痛的一线治疗方案，而且它们伴随着一系列负面副作用。因此，我们越来越意识到，我们应该更保守地治疗疼痛，为慢性疼痛患者提供多种不同的治疗选择，特别是心理策略，以便患者能够掌握控制疼痛的最佳方法，
their own experience, their symptoms, and to help themselves become more active and functional. You know, at the end of the day, it's not opioids or no opioids, it's how do we allow people living with chronic pain to live their best life possible. And this is where psychology is so crucial. And so what are some of the most effective psychological treatments? Yeah, that's a great question.
掌控他们自己的体验和症状，并帮助自己变得更加活跃和具备功能性。归根结底，这不仅仅是“用药”或“不用药”的问题，而是我们如何让慢性疼痛患者尽可能过上最好的生活。这就是心理学至关重要的原因。那么，一些最有效的心理治疗方法是什么呢？这是一个很好的问题。
So, you know, interestingly, psychology is really coming into the national forefront in focusing on the treatment of pain, and in particular in this intersection with opioids because the CDC and the National, the Institute of Medicine and other agencies have really now called for the integration of psychological strategies into the treatment of pain nationally. in fact, this has been lacking despite the fact that there's about 25 to 30 years of evidence that really demonstrates that cognitive behavioral therapy in particular is primary evidence-based treatment for pain. So, you know, there are other treatments that have been shown to be about equally as effective, for instance, mindfulness-based stress reduction, also acceptance and commitment
有趣的是，心理学在疼痛治疗领域正日益受到全国关注，特别是在与阿片类药物的交叉点上，因为美国疾控中心、国家医学院和其他机构现在已经呼吁将心理策略整合到全国的疼痛治疗中。事实上，尽管有大约25到30年的证据表明认知行为疗法（CBT）是疼痛的主要循证治疗方法，但这种整合一直缺失。所以，还有其他治疗方法被证明同样有效，例如正念减压疗法，以及接纳承诺疗法，
therapy, which is a variation of CBT. The best evidence exists for CBT. In part, it's the best studied modality. But most people are surprised when they learn that the effect sizes for CBT are sometimes equal to that of pharmaceuticals, but without the side effects, without the health risks. So can people find relief without drugs? My philosophy on pain care is that conservative treatment options should always be put forward first. Always, always, always try lowest risk treatments first, and that necessarily involves psychological strategies.
它是CBT的一种变体。目前证据最充分的是CBT。在某种程度上，它是研究最透彻的模式。但大多数人在得知CBT的效果有时等同于药物治疗，却没有任何副作用和健康风险时，都会感到惊讶。那么人们可以在不依赖药物的情况下获得缓解吗？我对疼痛护理的理念是，应始终优先考虑保守治疗方案。一定要、一定要、一定要先尝试风险最低的治疗方法，这必然涉及心理策略。
Psychological strategies, evidenced-based psychological treatment for pain, is shown to reduce pain-related distress. For many individuals, it reduces pain itself. It helps patients become more functional to live better, do more of the things that they love. It can help improve sleep and mood effects. These are often negative consequences of living with pain. And so when we talk about relief from pain, we're talking about certainly a pain score, and we're also talking about much more than just the pain score.
心理策略，即针对疼痛的循证心理治疗，已被证明可以减轻与疼痛相关的痛苦。对于许多人来说，它能直接减轻疼痛本身。它帮助患者恢复功能，过上更好的生活，做更多他们热爱的事情。它还有助于改善睡眠和情绪影响。这些往往是长期忍受疼痛带来的负面后果。因此，当我们谈论缓解疼痛时，我们指的不仅仅是疼痛评分，还包括比疼痛评分多得多的内容。
We want to help people live better within the context of having medical conditions and ongoing pain that can be incredibly distressing for people. And you yourself have had your own experience with chronic pain. And so for people who don't understand what that's like, can you describe what that experience is and how that helps you with your work? Yes. So when I was younger, I did have chronic pain. And when I'm lecturing and in fact working with patients at the group level, I will
我们希望帮助人们在患有医疗疾病和持续疼痛的情况下过得更好，因为这些状况对人们来说可能极其痛苦。您自己也有过慢性疼痛的经历。对于那些不了解这种感受的人，您能描述一下那种体验，以及它如何帮助您的工作吗？是的。我年轻时确实有过慢性疼痛。在讲座中，甚至在与患者进行小组交流时，我经常会
frequently describe my background and my credentials. But I really believe that my own personal experience decades ago with chronic pain is my most valuable experience because I have the lived experience of an individual with chronic pain, also trying to navigate the medical system and not understanding what the diagnosis might be. The truth is we know that pain is not just a sensory experience, even though I thought that it was, most people in our culture and around the world think of pain as just being a really negative or noxious sensory experience.
描述我的背景和资历。但我真的认为，几十年前我个人与慢性疼痛抗争的经历是我最宝贵的财富，因为我拥有慢性疼痛患者的亲身经历，也曾尝试在医疗系统中摸索，却不了解诊断结果可能是什么。事实是，我们知道疼痛不仅仅是一种感官体验，尽管我曾经以为是这样。我们文化中以及世界各地的大多数人都认为疼痛只是一种非常负面或有害的感官体验。
But in fact, the international organization for the study of pain defines pain as both a negative sensory and emotional experience. So psychology is actually embedded into the definition of pain, but that's really curious because we don't tend to treat it that way. We don't tend to focus on the emotional dimensions, the cognitive dimensions, the psychosocial dimensions, as primary components of chronic pain treatment. And that's what was missing for me when I was younger.
但事实上，国际疼痛研究协会将疼痛定义为一种负面的感官和情感体验。因此，心理学实际上已经嵌入了疼痛的定义中，但这真的很奇怪，因为我们往往不以这种方式治疗它。我们往往不把情感维度、认知维度、心理社会维度作为慢性疼痛治疗的主要组成部分。而这正是我年轻时所缺失的。
And so I had to figure those pieces out. I also had to figure out how to learn to self-regulate the natural physiological hyper-arousal that comes along with the experience of pain. brains in our bodies really react to pain with a sense of distress or alarm, we become prepared to escape whatever threat might be afoot. That's how it registers in our central nervous system. And so this is a beautiful part about psychology, is that we can both educate people how to identify what those signals are and what they mean, but
所以我必须自己弄清楚这些部分。我还必须学会如何自我调节疼痛体验带来的自然生理过度唤醒。我们的大脑和身体确实会对疼痛产生痛苦或警觉的反应，我们准备好逃避任何可能存在的威胁。这就是它在我们中枢神经系统中的记录方式。心理学的美妙之处在于，我们不仅可以教育人们如何识别这些信号及其含义，而且
also how to control them. And so that was really my own journey, learning how to do that for myself. And so I bring forward my lived experience and also my experience as a doctoral psychologist and researcher now on these treatments. And you lighted right into my next question about how instinctually humans, I would say, any of most other beings,
还可以教育他们如何控制这些信号。这就是我自己的旅程，学习如何为自己做到这一点。因此，我带来了我的亲身经历，以及我现在作为博士心理学家和研究员在这些治疗方法上的经验。您刚才正好引出了我的下一个问题，即人类——我想说，大多数其他生物——本能地
have a desire to escape pain. So are there instances when pain is a good thing. Do you know about that? Yes, absolutely. Pain helps us survive. So, you know, pain is really there, you know, to ensure our safety and our survival.
都有逃避疼痛的欲望。那么，疼痛在某些情况下是好事吗？您了解这一点吗？是的，绝对是。疼痛帮助我们生存。所以，疼痛的存在确实是为了确保我们的安全和生存。
And so, you know, the best example is if you were to place your hand on a hot stove and you feel that pain, that's a very useful signal because you are going to be highly motivated to escape it. You are going to pull your hand away so quickly. You don't even have to think about it. It happens automatically. That's how primal.
最好的例子是，如果你把手放在热炉子上，你感到了疼痛，那是一个非常有用的信号，因为你会非常有动力去逃避它。你会迅速地把手缩回来。你甚至不需要思考。它是自动发生的。这就是疼痛的原始性。
pain is. But, you know, while we're all motivated to escape pain, we're not born with the understanding of how to modulate pain and the distress that it causes us. So when we have ongoing pain with no way to escape it, you can't run away from your migraines, you can't pull your hand away from whatever medical diagnosis you have, but those signals are still firing and still causing distress. This is necessarily a psychological. issue. And it's normal. It's human. We all have these same reactions. We're hardwired to react and respond this way to pain. But the important message for people is that we're able to control it using evidence-based psychological strategies and techniques. And that's where our freedom lies.
但是，虽然我们都有逃避疼痛的动力，但我们天生并不了解如何调节疼痛以及它带给我们的痛苦。所以，当我们有持续的疼痛且无法逃避时——你无法逃离你的偏头痛，你无法从任何医疗诊断中缩回你的手——但这些信号仍在发射并持续造成痛苦。这必然是一个心理问题。这是正常的，是人性的一部分。我们对疼痛都有同样的反应。我们天生就是这样反应和应对疼痛的。但对人们来说，重要的信息是，我们能够利用循证心理策略和技术来控制它。这就是我们自由所在。
That's where we're able to gain relief and start to realize that we can control so much of our experience and that allows us to need fewer doctors and fewer pills. And you've also, some of the, your published works, you talk about relaxation and the importance of meditation and in this whole encapsulating way of dealing with pain. Can you talk a little about the importance of relaxation, mindfulness, it's a big hot topic these days in general. So how does that relate to pain management? Absolutely.
这就是我们能够获得缓解并开始意识到我们可以控制大部分体验的地方，这使我们减少对医生和药物的依赖。在您的一些出版作品中，您谈到了放松以及冥想的重要性，以及这种处理疼痛的整体方式。您能谈谈放松和正念的重要性吗？这在当今是一个非常热门的话题。那么它与疼痛管理有什么关系呢？当然。
So it really links in with one of the concepts we were just touching on, which is when our nervous system registers pain, no matter where we feel it in our body, it's processed in our central nervous system. And that is our brain and our spinal cord. And it necessarily registers as a threat. And so our brain and our body are going to be, you know, poised to help us escape that. It's going to lead to a whole host of physiological and psychological cascade related to distress or simply stress. So we'll have an elevated heart rate, our muscles will tense, blood vessels can constrict, we can become very agitated, our breathing changes. And so for some people they may say, well, you know, my breathing becomes short and shallow. And for others, they may say,
这确实与我们刚才提到的一个概念有关，即当我们的神经系统记录到疼痛时，无论我们在身体的哪个部位感觉到它，它都会在中枢神经系统中进行处理。也就是我们的大脑和脊髓。它必然会被记录为一种威胁。因此，我们的大脑和身体会准备好帮助我们逃避它。这会导致一系列与痛苦或单纯压力相关的生理和心理连锁反应。所以我们会心率加快、肌肉紧张、血管收缩、变得非常烦躁、呼吸改变。有些人可能会说，我的呼吸变得短促而浅，而另一些人可能会说，
you know, I really feel like my breathing stops when I'm experiencing pain. Over time, these become patterns of responses that actually shape not only physiological patterns, neuromuscular patterns, but they actually contribute to the shaping of our brain patterns and brain functioning, so that over time we can evidence that the structure and the functioning of the brain is changed simply by how we are responding to pain. So the relaxation response can be incredibly useful because it counteracts all of these pain and stress responses. It's the first most important tool that individuals can learn. I describe it as being your antidote to the way that pain shows up in your body and the way
我真的觉得我在经历疼痛时呼吸停止了。随着时间的推移，这些反应模式不仅塑造了生理模式和神经肌肉模式，实际上还促成了我们大脑模式和大脑功能的塑造，以至于随着时间的推移，我们可以证明大脑的结构和功能仅仅因为我们应对疼痛的方式而发生了改变。因此，放松反应可以非常有用，因为它抵消了所有这些疼痛和压力反应。这是个人可以学习的第一且最重要的工具。我将其描述为应对疼痛在身体中表现方式及其负面影响的解毒剂。
that it can negatively impact your body. Now using the relaxation response once isn't going to cure your chronic pain, of course. But when these skills are used regularly over time, an individual learning. how they can essentially calm their nervous system on demand, dampen pain processing in the nervous system, and this can lead to beneficial alterations in these neuromuscular patterns that essentially begin to prime us for relief.
当然，使用一次放松反应并不能治愈你的慢性疼痛。但是，当这些技能随着时间的推移被定期使用时，个人学习如何从本质上按需平静神经系统，抑制神经系统中的疼痛处理过程，这可以导致这些神经肌肉模式的有益改变，从而从根本上为缓解疼痛做好准备。
And there's very often news coverage about this topic. So as a pain psychologist, what do you think is missing from the national conversation? in the media about the opioid epidemic? About the opioid epidemic. I feel that psychology is not integrated enough into the national conversation. Granted, that is changing.
关于这个话题的新闻报道非常多。作为一名疼痛心理学家，您认为媒体在关于阿片类药物流行的全国性讨论中缺少了什么？关于阿片类药物流行，我觉得心理学在全国性讨论中整合得还不够。当然，这种情况正在改变。
There has been increasing discussions about the role of psychology in the treatment of pain and also in addressing us preventing opioid prescriptions and also helping patients deprescribe their opioids. opioids and this is really the focus of my work I am working on a nationally funded project that is helping deprescribe opioids and in over 1,300 individuals with chronic pain across four states there is intense focus on how do we help people with chronic pain reduce their health health risks but remember it's not
关于心理学在疼痛治疗中的作用，以及在预防阿片类药物处方和帮助患者减少阿片类药物使用方面的讨论越来越多。这确实是我工作的重点。我正在参与一个国家资助的项目，该项目旨在帮助四个州超过1300名慢性疼痛患者减少阿片类药物的使用。人们非常关注如何帮助慢性疼痛患者降低健康风险，但请记住，这不仅仅是
just opioids or no opioids we need to get beyond that binary conversation and always come back to the fundamental issue, how do we help treat pain better? And when we focus on that question, psychology necessarily rises right to the top. It is integrated into the definition of pain. It will not be solved without full integration of psychology into treatment pathways. I also feel that at this point, policymakers, physicians and prescribers have very, they have an acute awareness of the limitations of the biomedical model and they're now asking for integration. So this is actually a sea change and the time is right for psychology to step up and be able to lead in this space. But the caveat there is that
“用药”或“不用药”的问题，我们需要超越这种二元对立的对话，始终回到根本问题：我们如何更好地治疗疼痛？当我们专注于这个问题时，心理学必然会上升到首要位置。它被整合在疼痛的定义中。如果不将心理学完全整合到治疗路径中，这个问题就无法解决。我还觉得，目前政策制定者、医生和处方医生对生物医学模型的局限性有了深刻的认识，他们现在要求进行整合。所以这实际上是一个巨大的转变，现在正是心理学挺身而出并在这一领域发挥领导作用的时候。但需要注意的是，
we do need some policy changes to support us in coming forward and helping address the needs of the 100 million Americans that are living with chronic pain right now. And do you yet know what those policy changes would be? I don't know what the policy changes will be, but I do have ideas about what they should be. So in 2016, my colleagues and I conducted the first national needs assessment for pain psychology, access, and training in the United States. And what we found was that, and we surveyed 2,000 key stakeholders across five or six different groups and that included over a thousand individuals
我们确实需要一些政策变革来支持我们挺身而出，帮助解决目前美国1亿慢性疼痛患者的需求。您知道这些政策变革会是什么吗？我不知道具体的政策变革会是什么，但我对它们应该是什么有自己的想法。2016年，我和同事们在美国进行了首次全国性的疼痛心理学获取与培训需求评估。我们调查了来自五六个不同群体的2000名关键利益相关者，其中包括超过1000名
living with chronic pain. It included doctors, nurses, psychologists, directors of psychology training programs. It was really a whole host of individuals. And what we learned was that psychologists and mental health therapists themselves report a lack of education on pain. They're reporting that they recognize that they don't have the training and that they want the training, they need the training. So we need to better integrate psychology into all levels of education, psychology education at the undergraduate level, the graduate level, the postgraduate
慢性疼痛患者。其中包括医生、护士、心理学家、心理学培训项目主任。这确实是一大群人。我们了解到，心理学家和心理健康治疗师自己报告说缺乏疼痛方面的教育。他们报告说，他们认识到自己没有接受过相关培训，他们想要培训，也需要培训。因此，我们需要在各级教育中更好地整合心理学，包括本科、研究生、博士后
level, and also community-based training. So such as at the APA, for instance, you know, having better pain education integrated. And this year's conference, of course, has a whole host of trainings on pain. So this is required in order to better integrate pain and pain education and pain psychology into psychology training programs, we will need some federal funding streams to support that education. No question about it. And then just as a follow on on that, we really need insurance and payer systems to better support psychology as primary treatment for pain, to dismantle any existing barriers to psychologists getting reimbursed. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Donnell.
水平的心理学教育，以及基于社区的培训。例如，在美国心理学会（APA），我们需要更好地整合疼痛教育。当然，今年的会议有大量关于疼痛的培训。这是必要的，为了更好地将疼痛、疼痛教育和疼痛心理学整合到心理学培训项目中，我们需要一些联邦资金流来支持这种教育。毫无疑问。此外，我们需要保险和支付系统更好地支持心理学作为疼痛的主要治疗手段，消除心理学家获得报销的任何现有障碍。非常感谢您的加入，达内尔博士。
Thank you, Caitlin. It's been my pleasure. It's wonderful having you. Thank you. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to speakingofpsychology.org to view more episodes and find resources on the topics we discuss.
谢谢你，凯特琳。这是我的荣幸。很高兴你能来。谢谢。《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他优秀的播客，如《APA期刊对话》，探讨最新、最令人兴奋的心理学研究，以及《进展笔记》，探讨心理学实践。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们的节目。您也可以访问speakingofpsychology.org查看更多剧集，并找到我们讨论主题的相关资源。
I'm your host, Caitlin Luna, for the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳，代表美国心理学会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。